All right.
Whenever someone just drops.
What exactly that?
So we stopped last week.
Yeah.
Just before I start talking about Stalin
and Mao in one of the things that
happened in the 20th century.
Yeah.
Was that,
or what appeared to happen was that as
soon as the classical religious
substructures in the west became
sufficiently undermine that they were
very rapidly replaced with political
utopian dreams and what appeared to
occur as a consequence of that was
generally nothing but disaster.
Okay.
It's not exactly a straight forward
matter to figure out why.
Okay.
I think the case of communism is
probably the most instructive because
it's the most complex.
You know,
you still see,
it's kind of interesting on the campus,
you still see people handing out the
Communist newspaper from time to time.
You know,
which I think is very interesting
because if there were Nazis out there
handing out Nazi newspapers,
there would be hell to pay.
You know?
So why there isn't held to pay when you
see communists sanding out,
communist newspapers is not self
evident.
Given that the catastrophic catastrophic
outcome of Communist ideology was,
I don't see how you can make the case
that it was any less devastating than
what happened in Nazi Germany.
I've been trying to puzzle that out for
a long time.
Why people have different attitudes to
towards those two different utopian
catastrophes and I think there's two
reasons.
I think the first one is,
is that the Nazi movement was definitely
not universalist,
right?
It was for a certain kind of person and
that was that.
So it was for Ariens and not for the
world,
whereas the communist ideology promised
like a universal,
like universal,
and so it's conceivable that it appears
and appeared in still appears more
fundamentally benevolent.
Okay.
Then the other interesting twist I think
is that,
okay,
the radical left wing philosophies were
very appealing to intellectuals,
which I wouldn't say that was so true
about the fascist in Germany.
Now I wouldn't,
I would also not say that the academics
in Germany and in other countries
comported themselves with a tremendous
amount of courage when the fascist came
to power,
but for one reason or another the
communist propositions appeared to be
more acceptable and even,
and even not only acceptable but
attractive to people who to academics
and intellectuals who are on the left
now.
When George Orwell wrote a bolt down and
I think he wrote more effectively about
that than anyone else because he was
also,
he was sort of a socialist by
inclination even though he was an
Aristocrat by birth and,
and he had a fair bit of sympathy for
the working class,
let's say.
Even though he had a very difficult time
spending time with people from the
working class,
he said that he had to overcome a fair
bit of class based discussed before he
could truly consider himself an advocate
for the working class.
And he took some pretty extreme steps
because he,
he traveled around Europe as a tramp
more or less and also worked in very low
status jobs including a stint as a
basically a dishwasher,
low level kitchen employee in
restaurants in,
in Paris.
And one of the things that are well set
about
the pine of Socialists or the kind of
left wing thinkers that he meant in met
in Europe who seemed to have nothing to
do whatsoever with the working class
except from an intellectual perspective,
is that they were driven in large part
by resentment.
And so one of the things that are well
said about this particular kind of left
wing individual,
so that would be the privileged
intellectual left wing who's actually
part of the ruling class.
Whether or not they would like to admit
it was that they weren't driven so much
by sympathy for the poor as they were by
hatred for the rich,
which is a completely phenomena.
And one of the things that I wrote about
in my introduction to maps of meaning
was my experiences working with the New
Democratic Party in Alberta when I was a
kid.
You know I was about are between about
14 and 17 or 14 and 18 I guess,
and I was,
I had privileged access in some ways
because the person who was the member of
the Legislative Assembly for our writing
was the only member of the opposition in
Alberta at that time.
If I remember correctly,
it was all conservatives and one NDP or,
and he was in our writing even though I
wouldn't say our writing was left wing
by propensity,
it's just that people where I lived
actually admired this guy.
He was leader of the NDP,
he was a good guy and the reason they
were voting for him was because he was a
good guy.
It certainly wasn't because he was in,
he was a member of the NDP,
and so in the few years that I was
involved with the NDP,
I got to know,
I got to know him quite well and his
wife and then peripherally I got to
observe the sorts of things they were
doing out provincial conventions or
national conventions and that sort of
thing with,
because when those conventions came up,
he would be associating with some of the
premier's of provinces at that time,
like Roy Romer now and and the leader,
ed broadbent,
and then a number of the leaders of the
sort of national labor unions,
and it was pretty interesting to observe
them because a lot of them were
committed people and they did have the
interests of the working class person in
mind,
I would say.
But then when I was just associating
with the party hacks,
I suppose in general it was a whole
different issue because most of them,
as far as I could tell,
weren't driven by care.
They were driven by resentment and,
okay.
My experience as a clinical psychologist
has taught me that the two most
pathological emotions are the two most
destructive emotions.
I think you can,
you can or attitudes cause I'm not sure
they're exactly emotions is resentment
and arrogance
and resentment seems to be something
like the observation that the world is
not a fair place,
but worse than that,
that it's not a fair place in a manner
that's particularly unfair to you
because it's obvious that the world
isn't a fair place.
It's predicated,
you know,
the world is a tragic place and there's
justice.
If there's any justice,
it's imperfect justice and you might
think,
well how can you not be resentful under
those conditions?
But,
and I think that's a powerful argument.
How can you not are a powerful question.
How can you not be resentful under those
conditions?
But I can tell you that all it does is
make it worse.
And it's an interesting,
it's very interesting form of worse
because people justify their resentment
against the system or against being
itself for that matter by rationalizing
to themselves the fact that it's so
clearly on just that that having any
admiration or support for it verges on
the pathological.
But the problem with that is that as
soon as you adopt that attitude,
you start to act in ways that make the
conditions that you were originally
objecting to much worse.
So then instead of being at least
neutral with regards to the problem,
you're accelerating and strengthening
the original issue.
And I really think that's true with
resentment and nature actually wrote a
fair bit about resentment.
He called it [inaudible] tomorrow I
think is if,
if I'm pronouncing that correctly.
Yes.
I'm wondering like that,
but I'm wondering how you would and
maybe areas that like if someone feels
like the world doesn't get them
anything,
everything's worth for them.
Like,
how do you reframe that or like help
them understand that like,
yes,
the world isn't fair,
but like not so much worse for you than
for any other how to,
how to get around that.
How would you get around that with the
patient?
Well,
it's a good question because you know,
that definitely happens is that's a
problem in psychotherapy is you often
have someone who has a chip on their
shoulder.
It just one way of thinking about it,
do you know?
And part of it is to disabuse them of
the notion that anyone escapes from
that.
You know,
because one of the,
one of the things that I think drives
class hatred in so far is that still a
relevant phenomena and I think it's
still quite relevant,
is that people who people have strange
ideas about who's rich and who's poor.
First of all,
especially in North America because most
North Americans think that anybody who
has more money than them is rich,
right?
When the fact of the matter is that
everybody in North America is rich
beyond belief compared to any reasonable
historical standard and that almost all
the problems that can be solved with
money,
like with magnitude of money have
already been solved in North America.
There's still problems of relative
poverty,
but that's a completely different issue.
Relative poverty in absolute poverty are
not the same problem because relative
poverty has to do with dominance,
hierarchy position and absolute poverty
has to do with privation and the
argument that there are people in North
America who are in privation because
they don't have money.
I think that's an incredibly
unsophisticated and weak argument.
They might in privation,
but the probability that that's because
they don't have money or the probability
that money would six that is virtually
zero.
So for example,
if you give,
I've had plenty of clients in my
practice and the best times of their
lives were when they had no money
because as soon as they had any money,
man,
they are in serious trouble.
The,
those were often people who are addicted
to something or other,
you know,
like alcohol or cocaine.
As soon as they got their unemployment
check or,
or even their employment check for that
matter,
they were gone for like four days,
you know,
and they spent every bloody cent of it.
And that was the end of that.
And giving them more money was not going
to fix the problem.
And there's lots of people for whom
having more money would not fix their
problem at all.
It's not that easy to figure out how to
do sensible things with money.
And it also makes you a target for
people to take advantage of you
virtually instantaneously.
You know?
So the idea that the kind of poverty
that characterizes North America is
there because some people don't have
money.
It's just,
that's just soul.
It's so unsophisticated assessment.
First of all,
it assumes that poverty is homogenous
and it's by no means homogenous.
You know,
I also grew up with working class kids
and hardly any of them graduated from
high school.
Virtually none of them went to
university.
A lot of them went off to work in the
oil rigs,
which was,
you know,
pretty damn spectacular from a
perspective of money.
They never had any money.
They spent it all,
you know,
they'd go work in the Bush for two weeks
and they'd come out for four days or
five days at spend,
you know,
$4,000
in the bars.
And that was the end of that.
And then they were back in the oil rigs.
You know,
maybe they'd buy a car after working for
a year or two,
but they usually,
you know,
and it lost their license because they
were driving while impaired or wrap the
thing around a tree or something like
that.
There was no,
the money in some sense had almost no
utility for them because money isn't all
that useful unless you know what to do
with it.
So,
so back to the resentment issue,
you know,
orwell's comment on and it's like a
psychoanalytic comment in some sense.
One of the things the psych that
psychoanalytic thought is really,
really useful for is that it always
makes you ask a question,
which is where's the other half?
So if someone says,
I'm doing this and here's,
and I'm doing it for good reasons and
I'm a good person,
then the psychoanalytic,
the psychoanalyst always asks,
well,
okay,
where's the,
where's the other half of that?
Like is it projected onto someone else,
which is almost always the case,
or is it lurking around underneath
causing some sort of trouble that the
person doesn't want to admit to?
Well,
that's very,
very frequently the case as well.
And so orwell's diagnosis for,
um,
the moral insufficiency of,
okay,
leftwing socialists Utopian left wing
socialists in the United Kingdom was
that they were just resentful,
especially the intellectuals and the
reason they were resentful because even
though they were smart and privileged
and well-placed,
say in universities and so on,
there were lots of people around who had
more money in theoretically more power
than they did.
And that was annoying.
And so what they did to,
to reconcile themselves to that was to
pretend to be advocates for the working
class,
but all they were doing was masking
their own resentment about being
improperly rewarded by the power
hierarchy.
And when I read that and I wasn't very
old,
I was probably 17 or so when I read
that,
I thought that's exactly right.
He got it exactly right now he wrote
that book.
The book was the road to Wigan pier,
which is a great book and or well spent
a bunch of time,
I believe in the 30s with a coal miners
in,
in the northern Uk.
And I mean those people,
man,
they had a hard life.
You know,
the coal miners would go out in the
morning and then they would have to
crawl down a tunnel way the hell
underground to work.
They couldn't stand up in the tunnel
because it wasn't tall enough.
So they started their work day,
which was very long and arduous,
like 12 hours long by crawling three
quarters of a mile on their hands and
knees just to get to where they were
going to work and they need to get paid
for that.
That was just like the morning exercise
before you got to,
you know,
take a pick ax and hack coal out of the
walls for 12 hours and then crawl back
home and breathing in cold desk the
whole time so that you were,
you know,
an old man by the time you were 45 and
had black lung and the working
conditions were absolutely appalling.
The company's owned all the houses.
They,
they charge the workers as much for rent
and food as they made,
except a little bit more so that not
only were they paying all the money they
were making back to the companies,
but they were falling into debt at the
same time they were doing it.
So,
you know,
it was no,
it was no joke.
And so it wasn't like Orwell was blind
to the basic horrors of that.
He wrote a phenomenal book detailing out
there working conditions,
um,
you know,
as an onsite observer.
But then he followed it up with an essay
and the essay was well,
given the undeniable misery of
industrial working class life,
why is it so difficult for the
Socialists Philosophy to become
prevalent?
And widespread,
prevalent enough and widespread enough
in the UK so that it has some permanent
power.
And his answer to that was,
well,
it's because most of the people who are
leading the working class political
movements don't care one bit about the
poor.
They're just mad about the rich.
And I thought that's dead on.
And I also think that if you ever do an
analysis of any sort of political
movement without factoring in the effect
of resentment,
you're just not paying any attention at
all.
The question isn't who do people like,
who are they supporting?
The question is who are they attempting
to?
We'll press with their support of
someone else and it's just as true on
the right as it is on the left.
I'm not making any comments at the
moment about the right because at least
on university campuses we've already
decided that the radical right is,
is morally intolerable.
They can't even show their face.
Whereas we're perfectly willing to
accept the radical left.
And that's something that never fails to
amaze me.
It also never fails to amaze me that
people don't even know that.
It's amazing.
You know,
because I know,
cause I've asked students this year,
after year after year,
the number of students who knows no what
happened in the Soviet Union or in China
during World War II pales in comparison
to the number of students who know about
the Holocaust,
for example,
even though they might not know that
much about the Holocaust.
That's what I'm trying to explain how it
gets,
well then I'll go a little farther with
it.
I mean,
part of the reason that orwell wrote
what he wrote,
he was really the first Western
intellectual who woke up to what was
happening in the Soviet Union.
And he basically woke up in the 1930s
now it got complicated too because in
the Spanish civil war,
just before World War II,
the good guys were the communists,
right?
Because there was a split essentially
between the radical left and the radical
right in Spain and the radical right
one.
And so Spain was basically fascist until
1982 under,
under Franco.
And Franco was an ally of Hitler and
Mussolini and so forth.
And so during the 1930s,
it was considered quite heroic if you
were,
I would say,
a young intellectual to go to Spain and
fight on the side of the,
uh,
of the,
of the left.
And I think that was
that kind of set the moral tone in some
sense because I think you could make a
case that in Spain,
the left wingers were the good guys in
that particular struggle,
even though it's not obvious by any
means,
that they would've stayed the good guys
if they would have won the war.
So I think part of it is,
is that among intellectuals,
the idea of the left as freedom fighters
took on,
took quite strong hold in the Spanish
civil war.
And then I know that's where Orwell,
it impact in part,
for example,
it was exposed to it and the romance of
that continued.
But so that's one possible answer.
The other one I think is the communist
universalism.
I think that that fascism was an anti
intellectual movement to its core,
whereas communism wasn't,
and it was,
it was often led by intellectuals and it
was really an doctrine.
Whereas fascism,
I would say was fundamentally an
emotional doctrine or a dramatic
doctrine or,
or something like that.
It was a lot more primordial because it
was,
it was race based fundamentally,
you know,
so it,
young believed that the fascists,
the fascism in Germany was a reawakening
of pre Christian paganism,
roughly speaking like,
you know,
like real,
like real really like blood-based
tribalism.
And so he thought of it as a regressive
movement.
And,
and I think that that's certainly a
position that's worth considering the
communists,
you know,
they laid out a rational description of
their upcoming utopia and it actually
made quite a bit of sense from a
rational perspective,
you know,
because when you start with a
proposition like from each according to
their ability to each according to their
need,
first of all,
it sounds attractive,
you know,
because the proposition is,
well,
you should,
you should obtain what you need from
society.
So if you're,
if you're in trouble or if you're in,
if you're sick or if you're hurt,
then there should be a,
a backup for you so that you just don't
fall out of society.
And,
and parish.
And by the same token,
why not ask of people what they can
contribute so that the stronger people
in the more able people contribute as
much as they can.
And the last April people contribute as
And in some sense there's something
that's universally fair about that.
Well,
you know,
as a,
as a set of logical propositions,
it's not self evident that it's wrong.
So,
and I,
I would say that certainly in Russia for
example,
which was basically surfs and Derisk
Dick Kratz,
you know,
at the point of the first world war,
because the Russians were just crawling
out from beneath a czarist monarchy that
was basically medieval in nature,
you know,
that was pretty attractive.
The question is,
the problem was who attractive to who
and the way it played out in practice.
And you can just imagine this for
example,
so imagine that there is a village.
And so one of the things that happened
in Russia and the Soviet Union was a
process called D Kula causation.
And the Kulaks were the co Kulak was a
name given to the farmers in the Soviet
Union who were in say in a given village
who were reasonably prosperous.
And so those might be people that have a
brick house and who have been running
their farm for whatever reason well
enough so that they could have a few
employees.
Now one of the propositions of the
radical left in the Soviet Union was
that if you had any capital,
so that basically if you had any excess
money at all,
and that would be enough money maybe to
buy a brick house and to improve your
machinery into hire a couple of people,
that fundamentally what you had done was
stolen that from the Labor of the
proletariat of the working class.
And so then,
and you can understand that,
cause that's a Marxist,
that's a Marxist idea.
The Marxist idea was that Labor produces
excess value and that what capital does
is vacuum up that value and basically
steal it.
And so there's never really any
appreciation in,
in the Marxist doctrine that there are
creative things that can be done with
capital itself.
And that Labor is actually rather
difficult to,
to um,
define,
you know,
like good example of that is with say
you're thinking about Bill Gates.
You know,
I mean,
it's not an easy,
it's not easy to make the case that Bill
Gates made $70 billion by exploiting his
workers or as customers doesn't seem to
me that that's an accurate description.
No.
Now you can argue about the details with
regards to certain mon monopolistic
practices and so forth.
But you know,
what I saw happening with Microsoft,
because I'm older than you guys and I
watched what happened.
The computer's really kicked in,
in about 1993,
although we were using them fairly
extensively by 1985 of the net kicked
in,
in 1993.
What happened before gates was that
programs were sold one by one and they
were unbelievably expensive.
You know,
so a typical word processing program at
the dawn of the computer age would have
been approximately as much as the
computer was,
which was way more expensive than they
are now.
And what happened with gates was he
bundled programs together.
That would be the Microsoft office,
Microsoft office suite,
and drop their prices by a factor of
probably 20.
So all of a sudden,
poof,
everybody had Microsoft office.
It was a brilliant marketing ploy.
I mean,
what happened was that he noticed that
the price of software rabidly plummets
towards commodity level.
Right?
And he just accelerated the process.
So my point is,
is that regardless of what you think
about Bill Gates,
the idea that he got his money merely by
stealing it from the Labor that produced
his,
uh,
products is not,
it's an unsophisticated approach.
It's not self evident in the least.
It's also the case that large pools of
capital,
you know,
you got to ask yourself if,
if,
if capital was distributed equally among
the population,
while the first thing you can be sure of
is that it wouldn't stay equally
distributed for very long,
not very long at all.
And the second thing is,
is that it also begs the question is,
do you want a system where the only
people who have substantial economic
power are actually members of the
government?
Or is it safer to have large pools of
capital somewhat arbitrarily distributed
in the general population?
So there multiple sources of power,
you know,
so if you think about what's happening
in China,
for example,
it doesn't seem self evident to me that
the rise of multiple millionaires and
multiple billionaires in China has been
a bad thing for the population.
Not least because those people hold
power that can buttress the entire
society against the overwhelming
centrality of the government.
You know?
And now you might argue that you know,
person,
they shouldn't have that money because
it's unfair.
And I suppose in you can make a case for
that,
but,
but it's very unit dimensional,
that sort of thinking.
And another thing that you might think
about is that there are certain kinds of
projects that can't be undertaken
without massive pools of private
capital.
So for example,
if you want to build a chip fabrication
plant,
it's $4 billion.
So those aren't going to get built
unless there are large pools of unused
capital,
more or less at hand.
And you know,
Ilan Musk,
for example right now is going to build
a massive factory to produce a new kind
of lithium ion battery.
You know,
and it's going to be staggeringly
expensive and he has no idea if that'll
work.
And probably it's hard to say probably
it won't because most things don't work,
but there's not even a chance that a
project like that could get off the
ground given it's unbelievable,
unbelievably high risk nature and the
demand for excessive levels of capital
unless he happened to have more money
than God.
So it's necessary to,
to,
to analyze problems at a high resolution
level and not fall into the foolishness
of unit dimensional utopian schemes.
And partly because the,
that'd be speaks ignorance as far as I'm
concerned.
If you use an ideological approach to a
problem,
all that means to me is that you don't
know what the hell you're talking about
and that you're too lazy to figure it
out.
And,
but,
but worse than that is that underneath
the ideological presuppositions,
there's always some kind of hatred of
one form or another that's never,
never agreed to by the people who happen
to be in that position on the
ideological spectrum.
And that turns out to be something
that's tremendously dangerous.
You know?
So I know someone who's a businessman
who's had a tremendous amount of
success,
although,
um,
it wasn't permanent success in some
ways,
although success is rel rarely
permanent.
You know,
I talked to him about both left and
right wing approaches to economic
revitalization in Canada.
And one of his primary claims is that
Canada's too unsophisticated and it's
legal and political systems to support
high tech industries against
international competition.
We're just,
we just don't have the power
fundamentally,
conceptually or legally.
And so he says,
well,
the left wingers,
you know,
their basic is that while you don't need
large corporations and they're,
they're more of a pain in the neck than
they're worth.
And certainly there's no sense in the
government supporting businessmen.
And that's just not helpful because most
countries that have tremendously
powerful say intellectual property
companies and which is where all the
money is now have a legal system behind
them and a governmental system behind
them that's doing absolutely everything
they can to support the distribution of
those companies out into the
international market and to ensure that
they succeed.
And then on the right you have people
who say,
well,
all you have to do is pair government
down to nothing.
And then the entrepreneurs can go out
there and make money and you know from
his perspective,
and it's an extraordinary well informed
perspective,
neither of those solutions are going to
work because the world is too damn
complicated for the answer from the
right to be,
well we need less government,
which is,
that's not an answer,
right?
Any Moron can say that in one second.
It's not,
it's not a co coherent system of
thought.
It's devoted to the solving of a
specific problem.
It's way to row low resolution,
you know?
And then you can easily untangled the
rights claims because,
because the right is basically orderly
and because there's somewhat disgust
sensitive,
they look at people who are reading the,
you know,
what the low end of the dominance
hierarchy distributions.
And they think,
well it's just useless bastard to never
do any work that are down there.
And if they would just,
you know,
get off their ass and look around there
be a job for them.
And the thing about that is that it's
true for a certain percentage of the
people that they're referring to because
there are unconscientious people who
don't do a damn thing.
But then it's untrue because there's all
sorts of reasons why people end up at
the bottom of the dominance hierarchy.
And some of them have to do with the
fact that they're not very
conscientious,
which is why conscientiousness predicts
success over the span of your life in a,
in a,
in a western democracy.
But then there's all sorts of other
reasons why people aren't thriving that
have nothing to do with,
you know,
their willingness to work.
So it's not sort of approach that's
useful for solving any sort of complex
problem.
So,
and then there's the additional problem,
which is that the people who are
offering utopian solutions aren't who
they say they are.
And that's a big problem.
And I think we learned that we should
have learned that more than anything
else by looking at what happened in the
20th century.
You know?
And I think the fact that like,
just out of curiosity,
I'm sure I've asked you this before,
but how many of you were aware that
stellan starves 6 million people in the
Ukraine in the 1930s okay.
How did you learn that?
Okay,
so,
so you knew that,
how do you know?
I was really interested in that.
So did you learn that on your own?
Yeah.
You learned that on your own.
How many people were taught that in you
were were okay after university?
Yeah,
university.
Okay.
That's good.
Anybody else learned at university
projects?
It's a very strange form of luck.
All right.
In a class like that guy.
But like
right.
And the 6 million deaths in the Ukraine
in the 1930s that's not like this by the
way
course.
Right?
Right.
Yes.
Well,
and now it's just the,
that's just the tiny tip of what
happened in the Soviet Union between
1919 to 1959
it was embarrassing.
It should be embarrassing.
Like it's,
it's,
you know,
the,
the thing that's so terrible about that
is that what happened in the 20th
century is something that we need to
understand.
We have to understand it because it's
the most,
you know,
the,
the commission of those atrocities both
on the left wing and the right wing,
especially when you view them from a
Nietzschean or Dostoyevsky and
perspective,
which is that while they were the
inevitable consequence of the collapse
of,
of traditional religious systems,
that's a,
that that is something that's so
important that it's the most vital thing
you need to know in my estimation.
I mean,
the other thing that we need to
remember,
and this is sort of creeping up on us
again,
by the way,
is that the,
the potential for nuclear holocaust,
which was really a partners in 1962 and
in 1984 was a direct consequence of this
utopian of the,
of the battle for various utopias.
And you know,
it just about wiped us out.
And the thing is,
is we haven't solved that problem yet.
We haven't solved it at all because it's
the old horror.
So Cyrus problem,
which is how do you stop your damn
institutions from becoming genocidally
corrupt?
And to me,
that's,
that's a cross cutting problem.
It's not like how do you stop the
government from becoming corrupt?
Or how do you stop corporations from
becoming corrupt even though those are
two perfectly reasonable sets of
problems.
I can't see how they're different.
Um,
but then how do you,
how is it that you act within
institutions so that you don't become
corrupt and also so that you don't
further the corruption of the
institution?
And you can be absolutely sure that for
all of you,
this is going to be one of the most
fundamental ethical problems that you
face throughout your entire life because
you're all going to be members in one
way or another,
have large and powerful institutions.
So the way you comport yourself in those
institutions is going to determine in
large degree the,
whether you're a slave or a free person
or a tyrant.
And also whether or not the institution
within which you work becomes tyrannical
and destructive.
And like I see this particularly in my
clinical practice,
lots of the people who I've dealt with,
their problem has been pathologies in
their workplace.
They're bullied by a manager,
for example,
or maybe by a coworker,
or they're driven to absolute insanity
by the proliferation of completely
counterproductive and crazy,
uh,
regulations and rules.
So,
and they don't know what to do about it.
Generally they're too afraid to do
anything about it.
And,
but that's not helpful because if,
if they're afraid to stand up and stop
it,
then they pay a price,
possibly,
often not the price.
They think they'll pay it by the way.
But,
oh,
but if they don't stand up and do
anything about it,
they also pay a price in my observation
has been that,
that although that's a price you pay
ounce with,
with Flash,
ounce by ounce,
instead of one pound at a time,
you end up losing more over the long run
than you do by standing up and having
something to say.
Uh,
your advice.
My partner,
he's a contractor,
the contract or another contractor and
the contractor was giving you a part of
my power is in your story matters and
stuff.
And then sort of sad like,
you know,
if not interested in doing the work or
whatever,
then forget it.
And like I said,
my boyfriend by tax,
not the best medication or whatever,
they said,
well you know,
you know him would say if you're not
prepared to walk away then you know,
you're never really going to get their
rights back.
So you know,
prepared to walk away.
You think strong minded like he would
absolutely put it in.
But yeah,
I can edit it down a bit from what he
would normally do.
And it actually worked out for the
better.
It suddenly,
oh hours increased responsibility
increased.
Once you realize like,
oh,
like you're mismanaging me.
It's not that I don't want to work more
is that you know that the problem here
and you want to hire someone else,
then I implore you to go do that.
One of the things that's quite
interesting about people who are
tyrannical is that they're often weak
and so they'll,
they'll push on you and they don't have
any real internal boundaries.
They'll push on you and push on you.
And as far as you can be pushed,
there's no ending to that.
And they may even delight in that
because if they're weak and resentful,
the fact that they can exercise some
power and caused some misery is actually
quite satisfying.
Especially maybe if they're,
they're also jealous of you for one
reason or another,
then they can really make your life
hell.
But
a lot of ways to my partner,
right.
So I think that it was coming from a
place of insecurity.
Right,
right.
Well that's a very common,
oh,
it's,
it's very,
it's very common.
I mean you guys will all experience that
or,
or meet it out as you move through your,
your,
your life.
Because there'll be lots of times when
you're in a situation where you're
smarter and more competent than the
person who's supervising you.
And you might have your head screwed on
straight or two.
Whereas the loss would be times where
you're supervising someone who's like
that and they have advantages over you,
you know,
so,
but if you,
as a general rule,
if you're willing to walk and you tell
the person exactly what's going on,
they will leave you alone from then on.
They will walk a wide berth around you
and leave you the hell alone.
Now,
you know,
they might cause some conspiratorial
trouble in one place or another trying
to get back at you.
But my experience has been that that's
rare than you think.
In general.
It's not very effective.
But unless you're,
you know,
one of the things soldier Nixon talks
about,
and Frankel as well,
and this is all relevant to the last
half of the course,
is,
um,
where should your fundamental value find
itself?
Now,
you know,
we've been talking about the hierarchy
of values.
You know,
I've showed you that idea many times
that your action is nested inside a
conceptual map and that's nested inside
another conceptual map and so forth,
all the way out as far as you can go.
And one of the things that I'd been
curious about is,
well,
how far out can you go?
And I think,
I think I know actually how far out you
can go.
I think the ultimate question I believe
for human beings is whether or not
they're working to make the world a
better place or a worse place.
Okay.
And you could say better by whose
standards are worse by whose standards,
but I don't care about that question
because I would say that for each
individual,
they're either trying to make the world
a better place by their standards or a
worse place by their standards.
So the question of absolute standards
actually doesn't enter into it.
So because if you're resentful and,
and while we'll just go with resentful
cause resentment moves towards
resentment,
moves towards genocide fundamentally,
now it takes a while to get there.
But that's really where it's headed.
If you're resentful,
what you're going to do is try to make
the world a worse place in whatever
creative manner you can think up.
And you'll know it's worse.
I mean,
you might be a little wrong and maybe by
accident,
some time when you try to make something
worse,
it'll get better.
But that's just a mistake.
It's not like you don't know what you're
doing,
you know bloody well know what you're
doing.
And I think people know exactly what
they're doing at each time they make a
decision,
not that they necessarily know what
they're doing across large spans of time
and not that they necessarily all of
those decisions because you don't
remember any of your decisions,
right?
They just start manifesting themselves
out in the world as consequences and
they,
and you also start to build systems in
your head that do things automatically.
And so like if you're resentful and you
act on that repeatedly for years,
you're going to build a little automatic
resentment monster at the back of your
brain.
And it's just going to do things like
that without you even noticing.
And that's when you become unconscious
in the,
in the psychoanalytic way.
You're bloody conscious when you make
the decisions.
Now you might not be fully conscious of
all the repercussions,
but you can't be,
but I don't think it matters at all.
The other thing that I've observed or I
think I've observed is that I've never
seen anyone ever get away with anything
they ever did and I think the reason for
that,
I think it's quite clear,
it's that if what you're dealing with is
real,
so it's,
it's there,
it's actual,
it has some structure.
If you bend or twist it,
that twist and Ben stays there,
it's going to snap back.
It's going to cause some trail of like
some causal trail of trouble.
Now the trail might be so peculiar and
bizarre that by the time it produces a
negative outcome for you,
you have no idea what the initial cause
was.
But I can tell you what tremendous
amount of what you do in psychotherapy,
especially of the more psychoanalytic
variety rather than the behavioral
problem solving variety,
which is also extraordinarily useful.
In fact,
it's primarily useful is,
okay,
why did this happen?
And you trace it back and you trace it
back and you trace it back and you trace
it back and then all of a sudden the
person goes,
Aha,
there's how the dominoes fell.
You know,
when,
sometimes it's horrifying because
sometimes the initial problem isn't even
the persons,
it's like something that happened
between their mother and their and their
mother's father.
You know?
So you can certainly be the person who
inherits multigenerational Karma.
I mean,
that's basically old cyrus.
You can think of,
oh,
Cyrus as multigenerational Karma,
you know,
you inherit all of the errors that are
embedded in the adaptive system,
you know?
And that's also what makes young people
often resentful about,
you know,
the power structure,
the patriarchy or,
or,
or the military industrial complex or
whatever you want to call it.
You know,
of course the bloody thinks corrupt and
half ready to fall over,
you know,
it is because first of all,
things get outdated.
Just as time progresses.
And second,
they get outdated and corrupt because
people are willfully blind and refuse to
update them.
And so you're stuck with that.
You're stuck with that from a social
perspective and you're stuck with that
with regards to your own individual and
familial history.
So you know,
that's partly why I wanted to portray it
in this class as an existential problem.
It's not,
it's not,
you shouldn't take it personally.
It's just a condition of life.
It's like fragility,
individual fragility as a condition of
life.
You're stuck with having to deal with
that corruption of society is a fact of
life.
You have to deal with that.
The perversity of the natural world and
the fact that you don't know everything
is a fact of life.
And then the chaos that underlies
everything that you come from and that
you will return to.
That's also a fact of life.
And so then the question is,
and those are ugly fact because I've
only concentrated on the negative
element there,
but those are ugly fact.
So then the question is,
well,
what should you do about that?
And despair and nihilism and resentment
or a perfectly logically reasonable
response.
The problem is though,
as far as I can tell,
is that all that does is turn tragedy
into hell and it turns out that hell is
actually worse than tragedy.
And I've seen this in many situations.
So a while back I was with a family
where one of their family members was
dying and not a particularly pleasant
death.
It was associated with a degenerative
brain disease.
You know when those are,
those are,
they're not as nasty as they get,
but they're certainly up in the plenty
nasty category and the family comported
themselves incredibly well.
You know,
they had a lot of experience with death.
One of them was a palliative care nurse
and most of them had some medical
experience,
so they weren't naive about such things.
But the family came together and took
care of the person who was deteriorating
and did what they had to to help them
when it was necessary.
So the person's prime caretaker,
her,
her husband was very,
very good at admitting when things had
fallen down yet another level and doing
something about it right then and there
instead of pretending that it wasn't
happening.
Which is a great way to catastrophe.
I'm like,
you know,
it was quite,
it was not pleasant but it wasn't hell.
They managed it,
you know,
when it pulled the family together a
little bit better and everybody who was
going through the experience had the
support of everybody else and there
wasn't a lot of garbage underneath the
family carpet that that often is this
sort of thing that comes up when
families are extremely stressed and
yeah.
MMM.
One of the things I think they all
gained was that their family tightened
up approximately as much I would say as
the support they lost from the family
member who departed now.
So that makes you wonder a situation
like that.
It's like,
well obviously the world has this
tremendously negative multilayer
structure,
but that leaves open the question,
which is,
well,
if you reacted to it properly,
to what degree could you ameliorate it?
It's pretty damn obvious that you could
make it worse.
Like that's easy.
You know,
if some,
if a catastrophe befalls you and all you
can do is run around in circles and
panic and you're just as maybe a
catastrophe occurs.
And it's affecting five people and you
fall apart in a cowardly and
pathological manner,
then they have two people to deal with
at a time of crisis instead of one.
And I can't see that being the least bit
useful.
And so one of the things that means,
and you know,
it's also something I really don't
understand why people aren't taught
this,
is that one of the things you have to do
is to learn to be competent in the face
of tragedy.
And you also have to understand that
that's not brutality.
You know?
Cause one of the things you might wonder
is if someone close to you dies,
how morally obligated are you to fall
apart?
And you could easily say,
well,
if you really love the person,
the devastation should be total.
And then if you say,
well,
it shouldn't be total,
because that just adds to the
catastrophe.
Then what that implies is that there's a
sort of toughness that you have to have,
even in intimate relationships that
allows you to remain standing in the
midst of a hurricane.
And there's something about that that's
kind of harsh,
you know?
So if you're the person who has to make
funeral arrangements,
when you're,
when are your parents passes away?
One of the things people might wonder
is,
well,
how can you be calm enough to do that at
a time like that?
But the answer to that is,
well,
it's exactly at a time like that when
you better have your act together and
that means you can't be too afraid of
death and that you can't be too afraid
of being left on your own and that you
have to be able to stand on your own two
feet.
And that in that sort of time,
there's enough of you so that you can be
of service and,
and support to the people around you who
may be,
have fewer resources than you maybe are
younger,
more helpless,
and that you can actually help.
And that's a much better.
Not only is that a much better outcome,
but it's the right aim.
That's the way that you should be
conceiving your development in the
future.
You know,
you should be the sort of person who can
be relied on when,
when things fall apart.
And I also think that that's analogous
to what we were talking about before
with regards to your ability to
negotiate from within the confines of
pathological structures.
You should not lay yourself so open to
loss that if you lose your dad,
it means you've configured your life
improperly.
So if you're so dependent on one person
that you cannot tolerate their loss,
then what that means is you have not
distributed your support properly along
all of the multiple sources of support
that you could conceivably have.
You can't stand on one leg like no legs.
You're,
you're done.
You're in chaos.
One leg that makes you too vulnerable.
It's not wise.
And so you have fortify yourself so that
not only can you withstand the pressure
of tyranny from the pathological systems
that you'll end up involved in,
but that you can also tolerate the
catastrophes of Mother Nature without
falling apart and,
and disintegrating.
Because say you may fall ill or you may
start to grow old and it's the only
thing that'll be,
I think that's exactly the same problem
is that,
you know,
I mean I,
I know the basic dimensions that you
have to fortify,
you know,
we actually,
we,
you've covered them in the future
authoring program,
roughly speaking.
It's not that difficult to lay them out.
And I would sort of think about these as
the central elements of human nature in
some sense.
No.
And one of the things that is worth
pointing out by the way,
is that most utopian schemes admit to
know human nature,
right?
Because they paused at a certain kind of
utopia to find that as perfect.
And then imagine that they can build the
human being that would fit in that
utopia.
That's certainly what happened among the
Nazis.
And also what happened among the radical
left wingers,
you know,
so they're going to build the new
socialist man.
And that would be someone who was
completely unselfish and devoted towards
the state.
It's like,
well,
you don't want to build someone who's
completely unselfish.
It's,
it's,
it's a foolish endeavor.
It's a,
it's a hubris stick and arrogant
endeavor.
You know,
you have no idea how much selfishness is
necessary,
but non is certainly the wrong amount.
Like I would say roughly speaking,
you should take care of yourself about
as well as you take care of someone
who's close to you,
who's best interests you have at heart.
I think you have a moral obligation to
do that.
So basic moral obligation you have to
yourself,
which is that on average year as
valuable as everyone,
every other individual is on average.
You know,
when you may have some elements that are
particularity virtuous and some elements
that are particularly,
you know,
we can contemptible but,
and those should be uplifted and,
and dealt with.
But you don't have any right to hurt
yourself and you don't have any right
not to take care of yourself.
And part of the reason is exactly that.
It's like you have to distribute
yourself out so that you're also not a
burden and being overly selfish.
It's certainly one way to to do yourself
in.
And you know,
it's also this sort of thing that's
never discussed seriously in the modern
world,
in relationship to such things as
marriage because we're very,
very immature in our conscious morality.
So you might think,
well,
why get married?
This is a question that you attempted to
address.
For example,
what's the purpose in marriage?
Well,
the standard routine is that,
uh,
you know,
14 year old girl who still believes in
Unicorns.
You know,
it's while you find the love of your
life and then fundamentally the
arrangement is and magic for,
for,
for the rest of your life.
It's,
you live happily ever after.
You know,
and there's,
there's something to that on the
mythological plane,
but you got to think that's not a
philosophy of,
of intimate relationship.
You know,
it's so naive and,
and undeveloped that it's embarrassing.
So with regards to marriage,
I mean,
I can tell you some things I know about
with regards to keeping a longterm
intimate relationship together.
One is you,
you can't lie to your partner and they
can't lie to you.
And the reason for that is,
is that if you don't know what's going
on,
you can't adapt to it.
So if the person's lying to you or
you're lying to them,
neither of you are there so you're not
going to be able to get anywhere with
that.
Cause you know,
if someone tells you that the truck is
broken down when the car isn't working
and you go up to fix the truck,
that's hardly going to get the car
going.
So we know one of the things we tried to
impress on our children when they were
growing up,
you know,
to some chil children always experiment
with lying,
was that if you lie to me,
I can't help you because you don't know
what the hell's going on.
So how the hell can I help you if I
don't know what's going on.
And you know,
people like Carl Rogers and his
certainly echoed in the psychoanalytic
community in la at large is that rogers
in particular said the precondition for
a therapeutic relationship is that the
people agree to tell each other the
truth.
Now young took that a step farther,
which I think is absolutely brilliant.
And it's,
it's a measure of his humility and
genius that he was able to formulate
this idea.
He said that in order to tell someone
the truth,
you have to tie them to use so they
can't run away and vice versa.
And that's the purpose of the marriage
bond from,
uh,
from the perspective of psychological
development.
It's like we all have a monster.
We all are monsters.
And if the person with whom you're
communicating can run away,
there's no way you're ever going to show
them what sort of monster you are.
And then there's no way you were ever
going to learn what sort of monster you
are.
And there's no way you're gonna know how
to control it,
you know?
And so part of what's kept me on the
straight and narrow in so far is that
speed possible during my marriage is
that,
um,
I know that I'm not getting rid of this
woman.
And so if I don't solve the damn
problem,
I'm going to be living it out painfully,
daily,
weekly,
monthly,
or yearly.
For the next,
for the rest of my life.
It's like in India,
have to imagine that it's like,
no way,
man,
I'm going to have this out here right
here and now because the alternative is
I'm going to have this problem forever.
And so is she.
And,
and the corollary of that is that if I'm
having a problem with her,
I'm also,
despite my own desire,
open to the possibility that it's my
stupidity that's causing it.
It's not like I'm just going to roll
over and admit it because I tend to
think I'm right,
but I do allow for the possibility that
I might be wrong.
And so if she can convince me that I'm
wrong and sometimes I help her make the
arguments,
then I want to find out because I also
don't want to have the problem every day
for the next bloody 50 years if it
happens to be my stupidity that's
causing it.
And so it's,
it's terror and humility that that lead
me to attempt to find out where I'm
wrong.
It's not because I'm a good person.
I wouldn't say that it's because I know
enough that I know enough to know that
if I am blind in some area,
I'm going to get hit by the thing I'm
blind about over and over and I don't
want that.
That's partly why I had you guys imagine
your catastrophic future.
It's like you need to know where you
don't want to go.
I also think that's why cultures,
part of the reason why cultures have
always positive heaven and hell or at
least heaven and the underworld,
because those are real places now what
they have to do met,
met what their reality is.
Metaphysically it's like God only knows
literally,
but as actual places that you could
inhabit,
it's like they're,
they're all,
you just have to wake up and look to see
that.
Lots of people live in hell,
you know?
And some of them are so deeply embedded.
I like to think of hell as the worst
suburb of the underworld and that's the
part where you go,
you go into chaos and that's the
underworld and then the chaos in
bidders,
you and you sink deeper and deeper.
And when you've got to the spot that's
so deep that you can't get out,
then you're in hell.
And people are there all the time
because their lives are so surrounded by
chaos that they can't fix them.
And that's really,
you do not want to be there.
So young's proposition with marriage
was,
well there was a variety of them.
They're very,
very intelligent.
You know,
he said for example,
that the reason that you ally yourself
with someone is because the probability
that your faults and your virtues won't
line up is quite high.
Just like you know you're not going to
get,
your children aren't going to get a
disease that's,
that requires two disease genes
generally because the probability that
you'll be a carrier of a particular
mutation and that your partner will be
at the same time is quite low.
It's part of the reason why there is
sexual reproduction.
So your errors and your partner's errors
aren't going to match up.
And so their strengths,
we'll cover your weaknesses that occurs
at a genetic level,
but it also occurs at the level of
information exchange.
So if you're lucky where you're weak,
your partner won't be.
Now often you see in marriages where
they start to really crumble is where
one person's weakness hits another
person in their weakness and it starts
to develop a positive feedback loop.
So,
so in my marriage for example,
my wife tends to be accusatory and I
tend to be guilty and that's,
that's a difficult thing for us to deal
with.
So,
and you know,
now and then it kind of opens up a bit
of a hole,
but,
and,
and that,
those little positive feedback loops can
develop all over the place.
But the point is,
is that,
you know,
if you're,
if you're trying to build yourself into
the sort of person who can withstand
tyranny and not contribute to it and can
keep the adversarial side of their
personality under control and can
tolerate tragedy without becoming
embittered by it,
then you're trying to hammer yourself
into a particular kind of shape.
And I would say that shape is
approximated by figures like horace,
for example,
or even more accurately the combination
of horace and no cyrus.
And the way you do that is by rectifying
your faults.
And one of the advantages to having
someone else around is that if you can
get a dialogue going that's predicated
on truthful exchange of information,
then you can repair your flaws and that
makes you way tougher and it makes the
other person way tougher.
You know?
And,
and there's all sorts of things that go
along with that that are very good.
So,
so if you're not cynical,
one of the things that you might say is
that when you fall in love with someone,
you're allowed a glimpse of what they
could be and then that alerts you to
that possibility.
Now it's just a possibility.
You're not going to get there without a
tremendous amount of work.
So the window opens and you can see
through it.
Some of that's going to be delusioned
based on your own,
you know,
faulty viewpoints.
But controlling for that,
the window opens up.
I think the latent inhibition is
stripped off for a little while.
And so you can see the person as they
might become.
And then that closes.
And then if you're careful and you
worked diligently,
then you can start making that
possibility into an actuality.
And that's then that the benefit from
that is that you do build yourself more
and more into the sort of person that is
working for the betterment of reality
instead of four.
It's perversion and destruction and
that,
you know,
so I said the ultimate external rang of
the dom of the value hierarchy.
Something like are you going to work to
make being better or worse?
So that's like the battle between good
and evil fundamentally,
which is why it's architectural.
And then the innermost ring is,
well,
are you going to manifest a heroic
stance in the world,
which means that your eyes are open and
you're willing to take on difficult
problems and not shy away from them.
Or are you going to be primarily
adversarial in your role and
communication between someone who's
close to you?
The bond,
and this is why from the union
perspective,
the viral is actually necessary is you
won't do the God damn work if you can
run away.
And it's a very interesting idea.
I believe it to be true.
I believe it to be true because I think
in many situations there's no damn way
you're going to reveal what you're like
to someone unless you know they cannot
run away.
Okay.
So partly because it's embarrassing,
partly because it's difficult,
partly because it's frightening.
You know?
And it's strange too because it's very
frequently the case,
and this is part of the union idea of
the shadow,
is that those terrible things that you
want or even that you've done are
sometimes pointers to parts of your
personality.
They are incredibly powerful and strong,
you know?
So for example,
here,
here's a,
here's an archetypal way of looking at
it.
So one of the things I've noticed about
men,
and I think this is a universal truth,
is that,
and this has to do with the bifurcation
of the feminine archetype,
is that right on the,
on the positive and there's basically
the Virgin Mary on and on the neck off
for all intents and purposes and on the
negative.
And there's like the whore of Babylon,
you know?
And so for men,
the Virgin Mary part,
his mother,
sister,
daughter,
roughly speaking.
So those are asexual relationships and
the relationships that are fundamentally
predicated on positive care.
And then there's mistress prostitutes,
stripper over here,
you know,
and the problem is,
is all the sexual energy is on the
negative side now.
And so what happens with the man is that
okay,
because they're not very sophisticated
in their,
in there
psychological integration or in their
worldview,
there's no way they can tolerate a woman
who's both.
So what they do,
because the negative,
the sexual element contaminates the
purity.
And so what they do,
men do this to their wives all the time,
is that every time,
once they get married,
every time their wife does anything
that's vaguely sexy,
they punish her by commission or
omission.
Like you're not going out in that are
you?
You know,
if you say that to your wife 20 times,
it's like she's going to be dressing
like a 50 year old peasant in no time
flat.
You know,
because she's going to be not only
responsive to that,
it's also very easy to hurt someone if
they go to the trouble of trying to
manifest themselves as attractive and
you punish them for that.
That's a much more effective punishment
than telling them that they're not
looking very good when they're not
looking very good.
At least they can expect that.
Right.
It's not polite,
but to punish them when they're doing
something that in some sense is virtuous
and that's it.
You know?
Neat.
You said it's,
if you really want to punish someone,
you punish them for their virtues and
what he meant by that is that's when it
really hurts.
Now you might say,
well,
why would the man do that?
Well,
first of all,
he's uncomfortable with the idea that
mother,
sister,
daughter could have any element of
sexuality whatsoever because that
contaminates the purity.
But then there's also his own resentment
and insecurities and the way they
manifest themselves is,
well,
I'd rather you were at home fat,
ugly and unhappy.
Then out there potentially attracting
another man.
And that's a pretty damn vicious way to
live.
And all it does eventually is turned
into mutual contempt because the man
produces what he's aiming at and the
woman hates him and no bloody wonder.
So,
so
part of you might think like in a
relationship,
because it has to encapsulate sexuality,
there's all sorts of demands and desires
that might manifest itself within the
confines of the relationship.
You know,
and those are the desires that may have
to be fulfilled in many cases with a
relationship outside the marriage.
Right?
So that would be almost a purely sexual
relationship very often.
But that only becomes necessary when
that isn't allowed and encouraged inside
the relationship.
That's a very complicated thing.
First of all,
each partner might have to admit to what
they actually want.
Well,
cause people are very unlikely to do
that.
They're afraid of it and so,
and they or they think there's something
wrong with it.
Well everything that's powerful.
Sexuality included.
I mean you only have to know trifle
about Freud to understand that has a
tremendously dark side.
Sexuality and aggression.
I mean,
those things are dangerous.
And part of the way people deal with
them is they just don't get very good at
either of them.
You know?
And then that's not helpful because it
means they're primitively aggressive and
primitively sexual and then they do all
sorts of unsophisticated things at a
whim,
not helpful.
So all that has to be tangled up inside
the relationship too.
And that's very,
very difficult.
They'd have an affair when they're
drunk.
Right?
Which is often why people get drunk.
Well really,
you know,
I mean that's why people get drunk so
they can do stupid things that are fun
obviously.
And no wonder because it's fun to do
stupid things that are fun and it's even
more fun to do them when you're drunk,
but it's not.
But if you're the least bit awake,
you try to make sure that you don't put
yourself in a situation like that at a
point of maximal temptation.
And like if you're resentful,
for example,
you're just waiting for an opportunity
to cause trouble.
So those
absolutely,
I mean one of the things that this is
part of the union idea of encountering
the shadows.
You have to watch what you fantasize
about.
Now lots of fantasies look pathological,
especially if they're dealing with
material that has been repressed.
Because what happens is that like the
more sexually unsophisticated and
useless you are,
the more resentment is going to be
tangled up in your fantasy and the more
extreme that's going to become,
you know,
so
you work backwards,
give or take.
So
more,
more.
That's kind of a Friday an idea.
So that would be a catharsis idea.
Relieving pressure.
What I would say,
it's better to think about it from a
Piagetian perspective,
which is how do you turn that into a
game that can be played in a sustainable
manner across large stretches of time
without disrupting your entire life.
You know?
And what part of what that might mean if
you're an adventurous sort of person and
you'd like to cause trouble,
is that you better figure out how to
cause quite a lot of trouble within the
confines of your life in a way that
doesn't disrupt the entire structure
because that's what you're like.
You're going to need trouble.
You know,
and maybe you were going to marry
someone who likes trouble and so,
Hey,
away you go.
You know Eric Norman,
who was one of most most apt students,
most able students,
he wrote a book at the end of the second
world war called depth psychology in a
new ethic.
And in there,
one of the things he recommended was
don't try to be better than you are.
And he didn't mean don't strive for
perfection.
He meant that for,
for example,
if you're having an extremely violent
fantasy about your father,
let's say,
and it's so violent,
you don't even want to let it into your
head,
it's like you better bloody well let
that thing play out and see what it
means.
And it's going to mean all sorts of
things that you are not comfortable
with.
But
that doesn't mean that the impulse
that's driving that isn't something
that's absolutely necessary for you to
integrate so that you can be powerful
enough to survive without being corrupt.
Okay.
So,
and it's no joke,
it's no joke because one of the things
that you've said about the shadow and
the shadow in some senses,
the adversarial element of the
individual,
but it can also be the tyrannical
element of the state and it can be the
pathological element of Mother Nature to
those things are all sort of tangled
together,
right?
Because like your most violent,
aggressive fantasies,
assuming you have such things,
you can think of them as a manifestation
of the dark side of nature.
That sort of an analogy to Freud's ID.
So,
or you can think of them as only
emerging as a consequence of the fact
that you are tyrannized by a society
that is out of kilter.
You know,
you know,
each level of explanation has its
relevance and its place,
but
it doesn't matter where you localize the
impulse.
The question is what do you do about it?
And you know,
one of niches observations was he said
morality is cowardice.
And what he meant by that was that most
of what people claim to be moral virtue
is merely their fear to do anything that
they would actually like to do that
society would deem inappropriate.
It has nothing to do with morality
whatsoever.
And what they do is say I moral not I'm
cowardly.
And part of the reason,
for example,
why people are so attracted to bad guys
stories,
you know,
crime criminals and serial killers and
all those sorts of people,
Vampires.
And you know that that whole destructive
force is because those
characters aren't fearful.
They're just what other people there
just what people would be like if they
weren't afraid.
Okay,
so then you might say,
well,
should you act in a manner that isn't
inhibited by fear?
Well,
maybe then you turned into a mafioso or
a psychopath.
Well,
obviously that's not necessarily the
final element of worship there.
Maybe there's something past that where
you have those things under your
control,
but it's not obvious to me that the
criminal in certain circumstances isn't
more moral than the virtuous person.
If the virtuous person is just
abstaining because of fear,
then all they are is a cowardly
criminal.
And then you know when that's an that's
an idea that's,
well it's,
it's a,
it's a neat chain idea in some sense
that was elaborated in large part by
you.
You know,
so,
because one of the things you have to
ask yourself is like if you're in a,
if you're in an organization and someone
is bullying you,
what needs to be at your fingertips
before you will stop it?
And the answer to that is you have to
have enough force to stop the person
from doing it.
And that's going to take this same kind
of forest that in some sense that,
uh,
impulsively violent hell's angels.
Biker is capable of manifesting.
Now that doesn't mean that you should be
all admiring of the hell's angels biker,
you know,
because that's not an integrated and
stable solution.
But it also means you shouldn't assume
that your weakness constitutes a virtue
because it doesn't,
it just,
it's just a place of weakness where
degeneracy can flourish.
So the pattern in their wife,
combination of roles,
what's sort of the flip side of the
bifurcation of like Neverland,
honor kind of thing and how that
sexuality for women looking at and then
how can we then raised in that kind of
tie furcation can possibly grow up to be
sort of deposit and or she's in the
Virgin Mary,
which is like desirable while also sort
of paying homage to the fact that they
have sexuality.
That's the question.
That's seriously,
I mean I would say in some sense that's,
that's one of the prime moral questions.
So here,
here's the situation.
It's like how friendly you should you be
with your husband's friend if you're
attracted to them.
Okay,
well you have to think this through very
carefully,
right?
Because the answer isn't not friendly.
The answer also listen,
no sexual provocation whatsoever because
that takes a huge chunk of the spice out
of human interactions.
It has to be Tz with limits and the
limits have to be very,
very firmly evident and continually
manifest.
And then it's fun.
And then if you're like,
if your husband had it is any sense and
he can trust you,
then what that means is that the whole
energy of the whole situation is,
is elevated big part of it because
there's no reason to deny sexual
attraction.
The question is what the hell do you do
with it?
And part of that is,
well you,
you make it subservient to the greater
whole and that,
and you have to decide what that is.
I mean we've been talking about that to,
to,
you know,
I already mentioned today what sort of
being you should aspire to be.
You know,
you should be someone who can stand up
in the face of tragedy and tyranny and
your own appalling lack of virtue.
You know,
that's,
that's a really,
that's a wonderful thing to aim at for,
for all sorts of self evident reasons.
And then the question is,
well,
how do you tangle sexuality up into
that?
Well,
not by repressing it.
I would say by using it as a,
as a sophisticated ability and that
takes practice and it takes
encouragement and it takes attention and
vision and it also takes the willingness
of your partner to allow that to occur.
And that's not going to happen without
trust.
honest.
So it's a funny thing because what that
means that is honesty and trust opens up
the door to gains.
And if,
if you're good enough at those games,
you might not have to go outside of your
relationship for excitement.
You might be able to get enough
excitement exactly where you are
and question a bit of a stretch.
I see you're out in the more,
more often.
Um,
are those people in a way doing the same
thing but with [inaudible]?
No,
they're just delusional.
Yeah.
I don't think there's any evidence
Soever I've never seen anyone in a
relationship like that who's actually,
who actually has a clue about
relationships.
There's delusion and somewhere in there
it's like the friends with benefits
arrangement.
It's like,
no,
that doesn't work.
There's a whole bunch of reasons.
I mean,
first of all,
it presumes that you can detach
sexuality from emotional commitment.
I mean every 16 year old,
what admirer of porn believes that or
would like to believe it,
but it's not in the least bit true.
How could it be?
So then it's also predicated on the idea
that both partners are equally committed
and attracted.
And that's never true.
One person is always way more attracted
in a situation like that.
Then the other,
even if they don't want to admit it,
you know,
and then there's the idea that you can
have a friendship and introduced
sexuality into it and it's still a
friendship.
It's like no that's not right.
I mean the,
the levels of naivety that,
that are underneath the idea that
something like that could be possible is
mind boggling.
It's like,
so this is fairly common.
Well,
so is stupidity,
you know,
I don't mean with your generation in
particular.
I don't,
you know,
I certainly like people talk about
younger people as being more foolish and
self obsessed than you know,
baby boomers.
But you can bloody well forget that they
were the most self obsessed generation
in the world.
I wasn't saying that it's common as a
justification.
That as a segue to the question of what
you would advise for some people.
Well the thing is is people are deeply
confused about relationships and it's no
bloody wonder.
I mean,
the reason they're confused about
relationships is because of the birth
control pill.
I mean,
that's a biological mutation of,
of massive proportions,
right?
It's probably the biggest biological
event that hit the human race,
that hit that hit animal life.
Ever since sexuality evolved,
this is a big deal.
Like no female creatures I've ever had
voluntary control over the reproductive
status before.
So,
and it's only,
that only happened in 1960 it's like
that's yesterday.
It's a blink of an eye.
And so everybody's trying to sort that
out.
Nobody knows what the hell to do about
it,
but you know,
what do you do with autonomous women?
They're annoying,
they're interesting and attractive and
they do all sorts of bizarre things,
but they're so damn complicated that
they don't know what to do with
themselves.
And neither do men.
So everybody's struggling along with how
to deal with that.
And then that all gets contaminated
with,
you know,
stupid wish,
fulfillment,
resentment and ignorance and willful
blindness and general stupidity and to
produce all sorts of,
okay.
Completely harmful solutions.
So,
so,
and we could go,
look,
let's go back a little bit and let's go
back to those dimensions of life.
Just because you guys can argue this out
with me.
You know,
I'm,
I'm perfectly happy to,
to,
to hear what you have to say.
What I've observed is that in order for
you to have enough pillars underneath
you,
because you don't want to be knocked out
by a single event,
it's not good.
And single events that are capable of
knocking you out are on their way.
Some of you,
no doubt have already experienced them
and there's,
there's going to be many of them in your
life.
So you need friends.
How many?
That's an open question.
[inaudible] is the wrong number,
especially for men because it turns out
that men without friends seem to be
unhappier than women without friends.
So,
but that doesn't mean women don't need
friends.
You need an intimate relationship of
some sort,
you know,
and I would say in the absence of a
better theory,
you should do it traditionally because
the probability that you're going to
spin out of your own experience,
a solution that's better on average than
the traditional solution is zero.
You don't have the lifespan to do it.
So unless you get really lucky,
you know and stumbled into it,
but it's very unlikely you need,
you need to do something that's of
benefit to the collective and it's
reciprocally beneficial to you.
That's usually a job.
Or if you're lucky it's a career which
would even be better.
You need a family of some sort because
otherwise you're just too isolated.
Especially when you get older.
So in that probably is going to involve
children and I think children are
probably 30% of life,
maybe more.
They might be 50% of life,
but there's certainly 30% you need to
figure out what you're going to do with
your time outs,
with your own private time.
You need to figure out what you're going
to do with that,
that's valuable.
Um,
and you have to watch your health.
And that partly means making sure that
you don't fall down various drug and
alcohol abuse holes.
So,
and then you keep yourself relatively
intact and like,
I don't think that's everything you
need,
but if you're missing any one of those,
then you're weaker.
Now you could probably miss one or even
two of those who still be fundamentally
okay.
You know,
because I don't think you need to stand
on six legs,
but you certainly need to stand on three
or four.
And so one of the things I would suggest
is that,
and I would say also learned this from
young,
is do not deviate in too many directions
at the same time.
You're lucky if you can deviate in one
direction without blowing yourself
apart.
Because as soon as you deviate,
then you're in a chaotic domain.
And there might be a lot of possibility
in there.
There are no doubt is.
But the idea that you can tolerate that
is it's possible,
but it's unlikely.
That's why most people are conservative.
So now,
so then the next issue in part is,
well,
how do you meld all those things
together?
And that's partly why I told you about
the Ph Eddie and ideas.
Because I think that that the idea that
what you're trying to do is to produce a
sustainable game that can be implemented
across large sections of time.
That's not an inhibitory model,
right?
It doesn't mean while you should just
crush your regression or crush your
sexuality,
or it doesn't even mean that they should
be sublimated,
which is the Friday and alternative.
What it means is that those capabilities
should be made sophisticated so that
they're actually in play all the time.
You know?
So if you see somebody who is
sophisticated and aggressive,
they are aggressive all the time,
always in everything they do.
But it's,
it's,
it's more like power.
It's not,
it's not impulsive Dick Damage.
So it's an,
it's an unbelievably useful thing to
have at hand,
partly because it enables you to say no
and you need to be able to say no.
Because if you can't say no,
then you're a slave
so
well.
So then you might ask,
well,
how do those problems get solved?
Well,
one of the things I can tell you is that
marital union is a human universal.
So the probability that something like
that is the right solution is it's
canonical.
Well,
maybe you can find a better solution,
but I wouldn't count on it.
So
yeah.
And there's other things that people
don't take into account that,
and that's partly because I think that
we refuse to admit them.
Um,
the temporal course of life is radically
different for women than it is for men.
And men have a much larger horizon to
play around with and women do.
And so,
man,
can I,
like I have friends who got married when
they were in their late fifties and had
children.
You know,
that's not,
it's not that uncommon,
you know,
and they're doing fine.
You know,
both the one man I'm thinking about,
he married a woman from the third world
and he treats her far better than she
ever expected to be treated by anyone
you know.
And they have a child and he is
absolutely dotes on the child and
everything seems to be working out fine.
But as a general rule,
that's not an option for women.
And so women have to solve most of the
problems in life before they're 40
probably before they're 35 and so that's
a real problem and no one talks about
it.
No one will admit to the existence of
that problem.
So what the reason I'm saying that is
because what that means is that women
have less time to experiment with
alternative.
Okay.
Modes of sexual being than men do
because the price they paid for losing
the time during the experimentation is
prohibitively high.
Not that I would say that this is true.
There are obviously exceptions,
but just think about in some ways it's
better that women kind of pop this
limited opportunity.
Cause I have one friend who's 29 years
different and she resentenced her mother
so much for it.
And that's probably what her father
you think because of the age difference.
Yeah,
because she died when she was 10 so men
can still like,
you know when you're on your deathbed
you can probably still have a kid.
Like I can't.
But isn't that kind of a good thing?
Because even though so many people have
kids when they shouldn't,
at least women,
this is a weird argument,
I feel like,
I mean like antifeminist but at least
women eventually stop having that
opportunity thing.
I want to feel like you're opening up a
bigger question and one of the bigger
questions that you're opening up is the
utility of radical limitations.
So people always assume that more choice
is better.
It's not necessarily the case.
I mean part of the reason that modern
people torture themselves to death is
because their horizon of choice is
staggeringly large.
What should I do?
Well,
you know,
if you're trying to dress a three year
old,
the three year old says,
I want to pick what I'm going to wear.
But then the three year old looks in the
closet,
it's like that's it.
They're stuck.
What you do is you lay out two things,
have two options of closing on the bed
and you say,
do you want this one or that one?
And they're perfectly happy cause they
got to choose.
But the choice horizon isn't so large
that it is anxiety producing in and of
itself.
So there is some utility in tight
limitations.
You know,
it's something to actually meditate on
with regards to the fact that life
itself is finite.
You know,
because people don't like that idea.
I said,
well wouldn't it be better if we could
live forever?
It's like
are not that fond of the idea that I'm
not going to be here in 40 years.
And I thought about it a lot,
but it isn't absolutely obvious to me to
what degree that should be extended.
And if it was whether or not that would
be better.
So then that,
that brings up the deeper question,
which is well,
okay,
the relationship between the fact that
things are limited and the fact that
they exist at all.
Like there's a relationship between
limitations in existence.
So for example,
there's a lot of things you can't do
while you're playing chess because there
are rules to playing chess.
But the fact that those rules are there
and that there limits means that you get
to play chess.
And that's a weird thing,
right?
Because what you,
what you've done is taking a large field
of possibility.
You could play any game and you're
saying,
well no,
here's 10 arbitrary rules.
It's like Poof,
all of a sudden there's an actual game
that you can play that has virtually
infinite possibility in it.
And there's something about that.
Like it seems to me that like we're
constrained potential and that unless
the constraints were there along with
the potential,
there wouldn't be any way of actualizing
anything.
You know that the root where genius
comes from Jeanie
and a genie is this magical thing that
can do anything except it's cramped
right up in this little tiny container.
So it's this weird combination of divine
possibility and stringent limitation.
And that's what human beings are like.
And they complain about the limitation,
lack or limitation might be a creek.
I think limitation is a precondition for
being,
I believe it.
And then the issue is,
well,
if limitation is a precondition for
being how best to handle the limitation.
And I really think that's the central
question of morality.
Now the,
the point you're making is,
well maybe it's not such a bad thing to
have a time horizon.
It's like I would say,
well it depends on what you do about the
time horizon.
So one of the things that I see that
really torture is modern people is the
availability of divorce.
You know,
it's a weird thing to think about,
right?
But you know,
people will ask themselves,
well,
is this a relationship I should be here?
Well,
okay,
try finding a relationship where you
won't ask that question.
You want to be tortured by that question
for the rest of your life,
or do you want to just solve it once and
then do something else?
While that's,
that's a tough question,
but I believe it's better to solve it
once and then to move on to other
things.
Well,
I certainly don't think that's something
to aim for.
You know?
You know what?
I know they don't think people do.
But you can make a case that if there's
an escape route,
you don't sacrifice everything to making
it work.
And I don't think you can make a
marriage work without sacrificing
everything to it.
It's too hard.
And so if you leave open the back door,
then you don't have to commit to it.
You don't actually have to commit to it.
And if you don't commit to it,
I'm going to work.
Well,
even if you don't leave,
you're going to be tortured by the
possibility that you could.
No.
Yes,
that's right.
It's if it's,
yes,
yes.
No,
you know,
I'm not saying this is right.
I'm also not saying the divorce
shouldn't be allowed,
although I think the fact that we
casually introduced it into our culture
in the late 1960s was an absolute
catastrophe.
I think all the evidence suggests that
because what's happened now is that the
only people who get married and stay
married are rich people.
So,
I don't know if you guys know that,
but you know,
if you stratify society by socioeconomic
status,
it's the middle class and above have
long lasting permanent marriages and
usually have children within them.
Below that,
it's serial relationships usually have a
relatively unfulfilling kind,
single motherhood and excess poverty.
And it's almost all for women because
women almost always have,
they almost always have young,
the young children,
they're granted custody or it just works
out that way in the relationship.
So it isn't obvious to me by any means
whatsoever that that's constituted an
improvement for the majority of children
or the majority of women.
Oh,
well for that matter,
I don't think it's constantly didn't
improvement for the majority of men.
So now these are all I'm,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not stating these as facts,
I'm stating them as observations.
This is how it is appeared to me.
And
some things you have to be all in for
him.
Okay.
Or you can't get what they might offer.
You can't hedge your bet.
No,
I've already said that.
Doesn't mean you shouldn't be able to
survive on your own.
I think you're actually more likely to
be the kind of partner who can battle in
a relationship if you could live on your
own,
because then you can say no.
Oh.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
All right,
so let's take a break and then I want to
read you something.
I want to go through a story with you.
So let's take a break for 10 minutes.